while octopuses sleep incredible
patterns sometimes flash over their skin
whilst awake these patterns are thought
to serve all sorts of functions like
camouflage or communication with
different patterns associated with
different stimuli like food or danger
but why do the same patterns appear when
they're asleep
some have suggested that this is the
octopus equivalent of dreaming
and now for the first time scientists
studying the brains of sleeping
octopuses have found surprising
similarities with human rem or rapid eye
movement sleep
this lab in Japan is home to several
tiny nocturnal octopuses that spend most
of the day asleep
researchers here use neural probes to
record the brain activity of the
octopuses and they saw two distinct
States one very active and one quiet
during the quiet sleep the octopuses lie
still with mostly pale skin and low
levels of brain activity
but every hour or so they go through
about a minute of active sleep
in this stage the octopus's eyes move
their muscles twitch and patterns
flicker across their skin looking just
like those they display when they're
awake
and the Brain recordings show that the
neural activity during this active stage
of sleep is also similar to waking brain
activity they seem to be replicating the
same kinds of patterns when asleep as
when awake both on their skin and in
their heads
this two-stage sleep system is
strikingly similar to what's seen in
vertebrate animals in humans the most
active stage is referred to as REM sleep
when we experience vivid dreams and it's
been linked to learning and memory
like with the octopuses human brain
waves during REM sleep mimic what's seen
when we're awake
the less active part of human sleep
involves slow waves of activity in the
brain and it's associated with tissue
repair building bone and muscle and
strengthening the immune system
unlike humans octopuses don't seem to
show the same slow brain oscillations
during their quiet sleep
nonetheless switching between more
active and more quiet sleep phases has
been shown to be important for health
across vertebrates so why not
invertebrates
scientists can't be sure what's going on
but one possibility is that octopuses
evolved a remarkably similar process
perhaps even for a similar purpose
this is even more surprising when you
consider that octopuses are so distantly
related to mammals like us
these sleep systems would have evolved
entirely independently
the inner workings of the octopus brain
have long been a mystery
their patterned skin controlled directly
by thousands of neurons has been able to
act as a proxy to give researchers one
way to peer into their minds but now
finally neuroscientific techniques can
explore even further and octopuses like
these may have many more secrets to
reveal as they sleep
[Music]
thank you